oi boa noite quero em nome da yasmin que
abriu o evento aqui para gente hoje
agradecer todo mundo que organizou esse
evento todos os alunos a equipe tá lá
atrás que a gente não vê mas que garante
que dê certo na apresentação todo mundo
que fez contato nesse momento possível e
antes de eu começar a minha fala tem
alguns recados um é que eu vou dar mais
perguntas do que respostas o outro é que
a mãe das respostas já existem algumas
delas são bem ó fiz e por fim desconfio
de tudo que eu vou falar que hoje no dia
que a gente vai certeza sobretudo a
gente pessoa mais aprender esse dia não
chegou ainda mas aí antes de eu chegar
nesse resultado dessa prestação conta
para vocês aqui hoje eu fiquei pensando
como é que eu ia apresentar o que eu
tenho para falar e durante a semana eu
vi várias notícias acontecer várias
coisas
se meteram a desafios do passado coisas
que eu acredito que já a gente já
deveria ter superado enquanto sociedade
e algumas coisas que a gente já superou
então voltando então para a gente
começar eu quero fazer um convite para
que a gente faça uma viagem juntos na
viagem de volta para o futuro ii
ah mas essa viagem começa no passado até
porque as pessoas vivem dizendo aprenda
com o passado aprenda com seus erros não
é principalmente a ver esse algum
momento e aí eu quero convidar vocês
para fazer essa pergunta para ter te
avisado comigo tenta lembrar pensar qual
é a memória mais marcante do seu tempo
de escola toma um minuto com você mesmo
pensa quando a gente fala em escola do
que é que você lembra qual é o dia qual
é o momento foram mais de dez anos que
você passou na escola tem que ter aquela
aquela coisa que você conta para sua
família para seus amigos que a gente
começa a falar sobre isso em qualquer
lugar eu fiz essa mesma pergunta no
instagram e eu tive algumas respostas
uma das pessoas falou que que ela mais
lembra se eu era um sarau que a
professora de português fazia onde ela
podia mostrar a arte que ela produza ia
uma outra pessoa dizia que
olá meus problemas para se encaixar nos
grupinhos que existem nas escolas as
panelas os momentos em que é difícil de
se encaixar e aí tem uma outra pessoa
que lembrou com muito carinho muito amor
que esperava por uma semana para fazer
chamava de jovens na primavera ter um
momento que ela amava muito essas coisas
me dizem tem escola esse espaço
sensacional que pode gerar oportunidades
para as pessoas que pode ajudar as
pessoas se descobrirem enquanto pessoas
o que elas gostam de fazer em outros
espaços da mente elas não teriam acesso
mas também no espaço pode ser muito
imprudente competitivo e apesar de ter
diretrizes sensacionais parâmetros
curriculares e várias outras diretrizes
que internacionais ainda vivemos em
escolas que são baseadas no projeto do
século 19 para que as pessoas atende a
demanda do mercado de trabalho
é mas aí a gente pode pensar e pensar
nossa vida se resume ao trabalho o que
faz de nós nós mesmos
e eu quero deixar essas perguntas e a
gente pode seguir nossa viagem juntos
ah pára e pensa de novo como era um
lugar que você sentia motivada um
motivado o que tinha nesse espaço como
era as pessoas e como a falavam com você
nossa próxima parada vai ser 2007 mas
tenta lembrar dessas oportunidades
pessoas que aprenderam a mão para você
que te ouviram que acreditaram as suas
ideias com certeza as primeiras pessoas
boa parte dos meus pessoas fizeram isso
tava na escola que você estudou
é bom agora essa viagem para 2007 é um
inverno bem diferente numa região de uma
base aérea na alemanha a quem inverno
sabe essencialmente quente e aí o félix
tava na escola dele ele tinha duas irmãs
morava com os pais esse assunto acabou
virando bem que levante na escola que
estudava uma professora percebeu isso tá
bom já que tá todo mundo vão para casa
de vocês e tem que estudar sobre
mudanças climáticas tenta entender o que
é que tá acontecendo e volto hein aqui
contar para gente tá bom espero que fez
isso ele foi estudou descobriu duas
coisas uma que um dos animais favoritos
dele o urso polar tava em risco de
extinção
ah e outra é que tem uma mulher manda
matar ai que tava fazendo uma coisa que
tava ajudando a evitar que isso
acontecesse mandar matar a primeira
africana recebeu o nobel da paz e
enquanto era viva eu tô 30 milhões de
árvores no quênia é um projeto que estão
sujeitos humanos de moradia direito as
mulheres e também tratava da questão do
clima bom félix pegou esses dois
aprendizados e trouxe a escola e
compartilhou com os amigos dele que as
árvores servem para ajudar a capturar
esse carbono que a gente a poluição que
a gente emitir no dia a dia e ao mesmo
tempo ele com inspirado pela mandar
matar ele falou para os amigos dele e se
a gente nossas crianças pudéssemos
plantar um milhão de árvores em nossos
países
e a escola ouviu e os meses depois eles
plantar a primeira árvore na frente da
escola férias estudava
e isso acabou se repercutir em várias
escolas um ano depois 50 mil habitantes
e plantados para escolas na alemanha por
causa desse primeiro desafio de férias
chama usado
e reparem que antes da gente chegar para
o final da nossa conversa final da nossa
viagem oferece não fez isso sozinho
wangari mathai não fez aquela fez
sozinha muitas pessoas ouviram
acreditaram e apostaram por mais que
alguém dessa risada quando ele falou que
queria plantar milhão de árvores
houveram aquelas pessoas que parar não
beleza tamo junto não vai ser fácil mas
não é por isso que a gente tem que fazer
tá bom essa viagem segue para o futuro
esse futuro tem um desafio está
conectado justamente comprou fé que
tinha aprendido os cientistas hoje dizem
que se a temperatura média global da
terra subir mais de 1 grau e-mail em
comparação a nossa era pré-industrial a
gente vai estar sérios problemas todas
as espécies do planeta especialmente
aquelas espécies que moram abaixo da
linha do equador pós-vendas é
oi e aí o que acontece tem uma série de
recomendações foram feitas para que isso
pudesse evitar se nada mudar do jeito
que a gente vive se a gente continuar
consumindo do mesmo jeito contendo mesmo
tipo de vida as projeções o que até 2050
a temperatura mais a terra suba 6° um
pouquinho acima de um gatilho
é só querem 2015 as nações do mundo
fizeram um acordo depois de passarem 20
mais de 20 anos discutindo chegar uma
coisa de como reduzir as emissões cada
país e mandou um documento uma proposta
do que as repúblicas comprometi a fazer
ajudar enfrentar esse desafio só que
mesmo sente comprei esse documento chama
coisa de paris a gente ainda sob 4° até
o ou seja para gente ficar baixo 2°
falta ambição ao no ambiente foi quem
trouxe esse esse gráfico para gente que
fez esse levantamento de tu estou de
todas as propostas dos países leu os
relatórios do painel e integral mental
de mudanças climáticas e tá dizendo que
falta hoje ambição nas propostas de
solução dos países só que aí tem algumas
soluções que podem comentar que são
eficientes e não custam tanto assim uma
delas plantar árvores lembra de félix
ele tinha proposto que as crianças do
mundo por muitos países 11 de artes
e esse movimento assim 2007 continua
começou com uma árvore na frente as
cordas félix tô com 50 mil no ano
seguinte hoje 2019 esse movimento já
plantou 13.6 bilhão de árvores
e passou um pouco da meta e é que eles
fizeram fazendo parcerias com ongs dá
dinheiro com a nasa e o cálculo web é um
departamento um é um é um é um espaço
onde estuda as questões climáticas
pressão em relação as árvores no mundo
eles cobriram tem da caaba espaço onde
plantar um trilhão de árvores no mundo
sem competir com agricultura sem
competitiva que a gente come
e esse é um milhão de árvores
implantadas hoje poderia ajudar a
neutralizar 25 por cento das emissões
que nós os seres humanos contribuímos e
vai lembrar o que está pronta aqui é
consenso na área da ciência essas coisas
já estão acontecendo
é só que aí o plantio de árvores da
conta de 25 porcento ainda falta muita
coisa e tem uma outra pessoa que
aprendeu na escola que ainda falta essa
muita coisa para fazer o nome dela ela
guetta
i agree também viu na escola aqui tem
muita coisa que a gente pode fazer a
gente não tá fazendo
e ela acabou de tomar uma atitude foi
através do pagamento não faz dela toda
sexta-feira vai falar olha políticos
vocês tem hoje o poder na mão
e vocês não estão atentos e atentas ao
que tá acontecendo que devia ser
prioridade por que que eu vou para
escola se meu futuro não tá garantido se
vocês estão aí não tão nem aí apesar da
ciência alertando a gente há décadas
sobre o que já está acontecendo que já
foi confirmado que acontecer
é toys a escola é espaço um dia as
grandes formações podem acontecer eu
quero que vocês pensem junto comigo que
tipo de futuro nós queremos viver
e o que você precisa começar a fazer
agora para que seja possível e com ajuda
de quem a guarnição que eu trabalho a
gente tá em escolas públicas e privadas
a gente sabe que um desafio tem
burocracia tem pessoas que já estão com
salários baixos um pouco estrutura às
vezes em uma estrutura às vezes em água
mas ainda assim aquelas pessoas que
acreditam que para você fazer uma coisa
que aquelas pessoas com que ela tá
trabalhando merece também tem
oportunidades
é muito de vocês hoje tiver aqui
oportunidade organizar esse evento tenta
pensar como você vai tá sentindo daqui
10 anos quando se lembrar descrevemos
aqui hoje e para concluir eu quero
deixar um recado das crianças da índia
que se inspirado pela greta gravar um
vídeo já tem longo mas eu vou deixar só
um trechinho da mensagem final delas
para vocês
a ignorar sempre posta the wild
ignorância reggae regional sub-15 will
be on time with cancer treatment and
almeida rodrigues like.com
bom obrigado boa viagem
[Aplausos]